despite popular belief this is a
completely legal move in chess here's
how it works
first a pawn moves two squares forward
second it lands beside an opponent's
pawn
third the opponent's pawn may capture as
if the pawn had moved one square forward
this is called on passant it's french
for in passing on passant may only be
played on the turn after a pawn moves
two squares forward only pawns may
capture on passang
despite the confusion the support
tickets and the white hot burning rage
that ampassae has engendered it is a
good rule it prevents a cowardly
opponent from bypassing your advanced
pawn without allowing you the
opportunity to capture
today september 8th chess.com is
celebrating on passant awareness day we
invite you to join us on social media
with hashtag onpasson